à l'énoncé du jugement c'est un ouf de
soulagement pour les victimes de valmy
rope la condamnation du néerlandais est
la même que celle requise
huit ans de prison ferme sur les dix
encourus assorti de plus de 10000 euros
damende pour celui qu'on surnomme le
dentiste de l'horreur qu'on est content
il/elle maxi même bon voilà mais je
pense qu'il faut compter sur rien
d'autre pour réparer les dégâts qu'il a
fait à vous avez bien vu c'est c'est
minable ce que ce qu'on nous propose
j'ai deux trous dans la bouche donc les
deux trous j'ai pas les moyens de faire
réparer
il aurait eu un peu plus parce que vu le
nombre de personnes qui ont été quand
même utile et je pense quand même enfin
déjà 8 ans mais bon il faut plus qu'une
chose pareille pour plus que ça
recommence qu'il faut penser aux
réparations et du tout saad
tu mingant qu'il reste à faire mais
l'essentiel à faire là derrière
il a payé puisqu'il a fait déjà en
condamnant marc van lierop la justice le
reconnaît coupable de la plupart des
faits qui lui sont reprochés
85 actes de violence et de mutilation
sur ses patients et plus de 60
escroquerie le tout perpétrés entre 2008
et 2013 à château chinon attirés par
l'argent dans la capitale du morvan le
praticien hollandais avait été accueilli
comme le messie
car il n'y avait plus de dentiste c'est
vrai qu effectivement il ya une brebis
galeuse sur mon 38000 ou quarante mille
praticiens bon effectivement c'est
dommageable pour les patients mais c'est
quand même une infime minorité de
praticiens qui d autres font
effectivement leur métier
consciencieusement
nous avons toujours été hyper vigilant
mais bon malheureusement il est passé à
travers les mailles du filet marc van
lierop pourrait contester faire appel de
sa condamnation à huit ans de prison
nous a confié son avocate hors caméra en
tout cas il ne pourra plus jamais
exercer sa profession et a rejoint la
prison où il est maintenu en détention
provisoire depuis plus d'un an